everyone has a choice
and every choice has a consequence
[Music]
we didn't defeat The Dark One
we set him free
Hello Rosman good to see you nice to
meet you yosha congratulations on the
new season thank you Maureen's been
heavily defined by her ability to
channel the one power so what is a
quality of hers from season one that she
loses when the access to that power is
gone but then on the other hand what is
a new quality that she gains in season
two by having to forge forward without
that power
oh good question I mean well she loses
the ability to channel one power what
quality does she lose with that she she
loses
um
you know the ability to sort of hold her
ground at a distance and be in control
so she she she gives up a a great degree
of how in control she feels and how
secure she feels it's security and
confidence
um so we see a far less confident Marine
which is a an unfamiliar territory for
the character and but we see resilience
and I suppose resilience is her trait
Hallmark of season two because we see
her have to battle this you know that
some of the same enemies and some new
ones
without recourse to the one power but we
see all the other things that make her
remarkable her ability to play the game
of chess so she's always 16 moves ahead
of her of everybody and her network of
informants who are spreading out across
the globe and we realize that we didn't
really fully understand that before
um we see her smarts and we we see her
intelligence
I like seeing her rise to the occasion
in that respect uh yosha I have a big
old two parter for you as well so for
for Rand what is a new quality that he
gained through the events of season one
that you have enjoyed playing for the
first time in season two but then I also
want to know something about the ran we
met at the two rivers in season one that
you know you deliberately wanted to hold
taitu to emphasize that he is still the
same person we met day one
oh yes
that's an interesting in questions in
many ways he is still the same way but
in many ways he's not and in many ways
he's trying to run back to the two
rivers but also the same time running
away from it it's always it's always
like that I've and especially with the
two rivers and the the two rivers gang
they they throughout the wheel of time
whenever they meet each other again I
feel like they they just so they want to
go back home you know it's like they
know each other's parents they've been
to each other's birthday parties and
what whatsoever uh Bell tines
um but then at the same time there's
this thing that they they have to do
which is so much more important
than that you know so they have to uh
and and Rand is um is doing that he has
said goodbye to his friends and they
think he's dead so that they are safe
and that he now can live or at least try
to live a new life by himself
I'm very curious to see how uh that goes
beyond episode four because that's all
we've seen thus far so I'm very eager
for more uh Roseman I'll throw this one
to you because I think you might have a
little more insight as both an actor in
the show and a producer on it as well
how did the experience of making and
releasing Season One impact the approach
to season two both in terms of maybe
applying fan feedback and also valuable
lessons learned about you know the best
way to film the show production was
well there are certain sets that we
dismantled that we wish we hadn't
dismantled
um uh or perhaps it's saved
um uh
there are um we've we've I'm I'm very
proud of the way that we've reimagined
the channeling which is obviously a key
part of the show Almost a character in
the show and I think we've managed to
set up this really great Avenue of
collaboration between the VFX team and
the individual actors so I think you'll
see fans will enjoy
channeling being much more Tethered to
the character who is weaving the one
power and it will be specific to that
character and I think it's super
exciting what we've done there and I'm
very pleased for people to see it
um I won't give too many particulars but
we've it's a big departure from season
one
um we we I'm also excited that we get to
explore the
the villains being you know verbal
characters you know most of our villains
in season one were trolleys you know who
are non-verbal and you know were the
opponents but you know you don't have
the mind games that we definitely start
to get in Season Two
um and we know that we just want to keep
fabulous new characters coming in all
the time to surprise people we've
realized that people love being in our
show and we can get a really high
caliber of actor to come in for a guests
star and and we've all really enjoyed
yeah they come in and have some fun
sometimes get better lines than us which
we get a bit pissed off about but um you
know we also know that we need to give
them some you know the bait to attract
them so we
you know we were happy to play second
fiddle to some of the great the greats
who are coming through our doors
no one should have that much power
[Music]
Madeline I'm gonna come your way first
with a big old compound question what is
a new quality that a gwain gained from
the events of season one that you
enjoyed exploring for the first time in
season two but then I also want to know
something about the version of a guine
that we met in season one in the two
rivers that you knew you wanted to hold
tight too to still make sure she came
across as the same person we met at the
start
absolutely
um
I think I might just start with the
latter question a lot of question if
that's okay
um I think something that I wanted to
hold on to with the queen that we
established at the beginning of season
one which I think she carries all the
way through the entire series is being a
novice of the world
um she's ever the eager you know learner
and has always got an open mind
um so that is something that I think is
really integral to playing a gwain she
is very curious
um
and I think something that I learned
from McWane uh going into season two is
is really her resilience
um
the resilience she had to continue on to
push forward to strive for greatness
um and to play her part in you know the
Turning of the wheel uh even when we
find her in season two and she is
feeling insecure and having a bit of an
identity crisis
I think that is still at the heart of um
what she is seeking out oh I am coming
back to that identity crisis but first
uh
to you so so much of who land in Lan is
has been tied to who he is to Moraine so
what was it like exploring the push-pull
of maintaining that in season two while
also trying to figure out who he is as
an individual on his own
both very fun both very satisfying I
think um
the push-pull is very much you know
Rosman and I focused a lot on that how
we could make that work what the tone
was and um it's always tricky because we
you know we've we built a foundation
with these two characters in season one
and it was very calm and it was very
even and so when this sort of when the
This Disaster sort of started it was it
was different for both of us so you know
it's a kind of a vague answer but we're
happy with how it turned out I was more
I'm very excited to uh you know people
to see this solo Journey that he went on
because I think
you know it's almost like a formative
period for land having been you know his
parents being killed and spent so much
time with Moraine he has had a chance to
be on his own as a man and this is a
chance for him to ask questions to be
with his fellow Warriors to be with
people he hasn't been with much and
really uh really changes the person so
it's exciting
so it's a good vague tease I am going to
get into the specifics of one particular
scene
I gotta talk about one particular scene
though in episode one of season two it's
uh the fight you have with the Fades at
the end of it can you tell me a little
bit about filming a fight scene like
that and in particular do you find a
more intimate battle like that more or
less challenging than something that's a
little larger and maybe more effects
heavy
um I find that one that one was
incredibly challenging because
um two swords is is very daunting I mean
my left hand is nowhere nearly as
skillful as my right and to move them in
concert it is almost impossible not to
mention it was dark plus I spoke about
this before that fight was meant to look
messy and uh making something look messy
is much more difficult than making
something look good
um so that's almost like you have to
take it apart after you perfect it and
now you know what I mean dissect it and
make it look worse so it was very very
challenging but hopefully it turned out
okay very very effective that quality of
it makes it more visceral and makes us
feel every blow that is landed
throughout that whole sequence so job
especially well done in that respect all
right Madeline I'm coming back to the
idea of of like her having a little bit
of an identity crisis particularly
particularly in terms of the jealous
side of her that we're starting to see
at the very beginning of season two what
do you think Sparks that that jealousy
in her the most is it you know the need
for her friend's attention the eyes to
die is attention or is it an actual
interest in having power and authority
in this situation
I think it's all of the above really
um
she's very much an idealist and I think
she had an expectation of what the white
towel would be like and how she would be
accepted there
um you know
the way that naive is moving up the
ranks so effortlessly is in really
infuriating to her because she's trying
everything she can she's so desperate to
impress and do the right thing and uh
you know she's just really become
invisible
um I think that you know
for her having her confidence and her
self-worth rocked uh is a massive blow
to her and you know this is where her
relationship with Elaine is so important
because she is someone that helps her
build her confidence back up
um is a really great confident and this
is something that we will see with the
queen constantly throughout the season
is she is constantly trialled and tested
um her strength is tested and um you
know she gains a better understanding of
her abilities and also her ideas of the
White Tower and what that means to her
change is really dramatically
there are many paths to walk through
tonight
it's not always the most powerful who
might history
I am starting out with a big old
compound question for you what is a new
quality that naive gained during the
events of season one that you got to
play with for the very first time in
season two but then I also want to know
what is something about the naive that
we met in the two rivers in season one
that you deliberately wanted to hold
especially tight to so that we still get
the feeling that to some degree at least
she's the same person
oh what a great question
I think I think what's wonderful about
nine neighbors that she will always be
her
she she doesn't suffer Falls what you
see is what you get she will not change
for anyone
um and I think she will always be there
I think
what's been wonderful to
play with in in season two is more of
her vulnerability she can come across as
very
um
assertive and strong in her convictions
which she is but she's also just like
jelly underneath and she cares so much
about the people she loves she will do
absolutely anything for them so I think
it's been wonderful to play with with
this kind of stone-faced
um
face character and and also delve deep
into her heart
yeah there's a very accurate description
given how much I've seen thus far so you
kind of touched on this a little bit she
does have a habit of rebelling against
those in charge so it was making me
wonder at this point in her journey what
qualities do you think she would respect
most in a leader I think she probably
would respect someone who tells it like
it is
um and to be honest I think we we've
seen this in season one Moraine is you
know not that person at all so that's
something that native absolutely can't
can't handle
um
I I do think they need this is someone
who's a bit of a hypocrite though she's
she's obviously a an authority figure
herself she's from the two rivers and
she was of wisdom so she is someone that
has you know leadership and a leadership
role
um but she absolutely hates Authority
and and hates to be told what to do
herself so yeah she's a bit of a she's a
bit of a walking contradiction
I'm gonna add another layer to that
whole idea right now so let's say naive
became the leader of the eyes to die she
was the new amerlin seat what do you
think the very first thing she would
change about how things are run at the
White Tower and also Beyond I guess
I think she would potentially change the
the hierarchical system I think we see
that in the beginning there's this
discomfort being a novice and that's
essentially starting at the bottom and
you're having to work your way up I
don't think she has any time for that I
think she'd probably like to see some
like an institution that works more
cohesively in the same way that the two
rivers did so that's yeah that's maybe
what should change okay like that sign
me up for her version I much prefer that
I want to talk specifically about naive
scenes with leandrin because I found
them to be some of the most electric
ones of the first few episodes that we
were able to screen so can you tell me a
little bit about working with Kate and
you know maybe specifically something
about her as a scene partner that helped
you reach something in naive that you
would not have been able to without her
yeah Kate is someone who's just like
completely opposite to liandrin which is
so funny she is so warm and engaging and
giving and loving she's been actually a
really
she's been a massive support person for
me on set um we've had as you say we've
had to do some really intense scenes
together and that requires a lot of
trust I 100 trust her
um
I think I think this just a generosity
that's required to to get to a level of
of play and openness and excitement that
that I share when I'm doing scenes with
Kate and she she always gives that we've
been given the the joy of playing some
really interesting characters that have
a very distinct
um relationship and I think we've both
been so excited by that Prospect so yeah
we're both leaned into that I love that
Dynamic so much and finally very briefly
what is your favorite episode of season
two I'm going to say
three
I've only seen up to four but at this
point I will say that is the right
answer
[Laughter]
the ones who survive
[Music]
you're not a Spoke boy you are the water
the turns the wheel itself all right
don't all come your way first because
joining a show in the second season can
be very intimidating so do you remember
the very first moment when the Wheel of
Time set felt like home like you were
amidst a bunch of artists that could
help you deliver your best work
you know what uh I'm absolutely spoiled
that I didn't have to wait like very
long for that moment to come
um and I recognized that as a blessing
um and I think that was because uh the
kind of the way that all of this
happened for me was like a bit of a
whirlwind experience and that was madly
exciting and it allowed me not to dwell
on any of the uh like you said that
there can be like a quality of it being
daunting or they're being nerves but um
I came into it and as you know like from
those First episodes they are scenes
that are set in one room with just two
people talking and that gave it almost
the quality of a play you know like
something like being a stage play and I
think because case who's phenomenal in
those scenes as well as as liandran and
uh Thomas kind of recognized that that
we maybe linked into that and we managed
to you know go to a studio space black
box and kind of run these scenes
um in in you know in Tandem and to kind
of find the floor versus that it allowed
me to feel very comfortable straight
away and then also those days and said I
got to come in to that space really
early on and it's a cell that Matt has
been in for months at a time so you know
I kind of got time to to sit in that
space before we did any work and to kind
of
you know I'll feel my feet on the ground
and to to kind of you know make up the
stories of where he's what he's done in
the room and where he spent his time and
that and so
um and that was all you know Testament
to everyone who was around us supporting
us like the The Lads and the set design
and uh and costume and and hair and
makeup and Thomas
um our director for those episodes and
getting to do the scenes with Kate was
just phenomenal like so I didn't have to
wait very long for a moment to feel
connected and rooted and at home in The
Wheel of Time even though you know I'd
hate for that to be my home that that
room
it's exceptional stuff to start very
Dynamic material for uh stuff that takes
place in one single location so a job
very well done in that respect uh Kyra
I'll go to you next is our second
newcomer here so we get our very first
impressions of Elaine via her
interactions with a guine I believe in
the second episode so I wanted to ask
you a little bit about working with uh
Madeline on those what is something
about her as a scene partner that you
know maybe helped you define who Elaine
was in those very in those uh first few
episodes that will then carry over
through the rest of the season
I think I was really blessed to kind of
be working with Madeline on those First
episodes
um she's an incredible actress with um
incredible body of work behind her so
she Not only was she kind of
um just so supportive and really helped
me kind of with those first scenes but
it was great to kind of play alongside a
Gwen and she
um she really has a sense when you're
kind of working against her that she
knows who she is and
um I think that was such a challenge to
play against as Elaine because I think
she thinks she knows who she is and she
knows that she's going to be Queen one
day and she she's
she's very kind of she thought she knew
everything and then she's meeting this
character and she's like oh wow she's
she's maybe braver than I am and I'm
meant to be the queen like I need to be
brave so it was it was amazing to kind
of have that energy to work off and um
and yeah I um I can I can never sing
Madeline's Praises enough
I love it I'm excited to see that
Dynamic explored further in the next
episodes uh Marcus you're getting my one
hyper specific question here because
you're at the center of one of my
favorite scenes in episode one it's it's
the speech you give about Pat and fame
and parent feeling the need to kill him
so what is it like preparing for a
significant monologue like that and also
particularly finding the right balance
between you know heartbreak fear and
also that really overwhelming sense of
Rage
yeah oh thank you I think um yeah I
think it was quite nice because he
doesn't really talk that much in season
one so I think it was it was I was like
oh my God like that's why more than I
said in season one but um it was cool I
think Thomas kind of gave and set this
scene and I think it kind of felt like
to kind of like mates talking like two
men probably struggling to actually like
get their feelings out within perin and
intar and we kind of set it almost in
like a contemporary context
um and I think yeah I think parents
obviously been holding this in for so
long
um but I think there's been a
camaraderie through their Journey
um when we find them so I think opening
up to intar at that moment
um it felt like something had been
bubbling underneath
um I think there's a rage like he says
that's inside of him that he's quite
scared of and I think he's quite um
intimidated of and I think it's
worrisome because I think it might bring
back memories of what you know happened
in that first episode in season one so I
think um he's still a character that's
not showing all his emotions yet but it
was really nice and those kind of first
kind of scenes to kind of go through the
gears a bit and show a different side to
it